ladies and gentlemen welcome back this
channel has always been set up to do
long-form investigations it's what made
the jay mazzini case so special
today we're talking about a crypto
mystery involving a turkish crypto
exchange
where 2.2 billion dollars may have
vanished overnight
and there's also an international
manhunt going on
alongside this that hasn't been solved
yet let's take a look
and see what we can find out if you're
an investor in cryptocurrencies
this has been a bad week for you codex
is no longer accessible
its ceo is missing and users are filing
complaints
alleging that hundreds of millions of
dollars
have been stolen turkish officials have
now detained a number of individuals
in relation to dodec's there's just a
lot of noise here and a lot of smoke and
i think we're just you know we're
starting to see a potential fire
[Music]
first a little bit of background thodex
is a turkish crypto exchange
where people would buy and sell
cryptocurrencies it was created in 2017
by a man named farooq fatih ozer ozar
oh yeah like what she said look i'm
gonna butcher it the entire time through
so just bear with me but that's how you
pronounce the name i will do my best
basically this exchange was well known
for its promotions to try to attract new
members and
they said they were going to give away
millions of dogecoins for free and
you guys know how much on this channel
we love dogecoins here's was their
graphic they said they were distributing
millions of dogecoins
and reports now say that most new users
never saw any of that dogecoin
but this probably wasn't even the real
reason people joined anyways turkish
citizens have a huge incentive to find
ways to shelter their money you have to
understand
the turkish economy suffers from
extremely high inflation rates of
15 a year and higher i think at one
point it was 32 percent
in a single year so it's a no-brainer
for many people to want to find a place
to park their money
so that their assets don't suffer from
that inflation it just makes sense
so understandably thoughtx grew quickly
amassing over 700
000 members by april 21st 2021
when suddenly everything stopped this is
what you got
when you went to their home page let's
go to the board
dear users since 2017 we've been
providing quality service to you and
working day and night to increase our
service quality even more based on the
satisfaction of our users we have made
many innovations to our country so far
and have become the first licensed
turkish company
in the sector globally with the license
we received from the united states of
america
world-renowned banks and fund companies
whose name we will announce
when the agreement process is completed
have been wanting to invest in our
company for a long time and offer
partnership
in order to provide better service to
you it has been decided to evaluate the
partnership offer
positively in order for this process to
be completed the transactions
must be stopped and the transfer process
must be completed
the process will take about four to five
business days
during this period regular information
will be provided
to our users now that's all kind of
corporate jargon for we're stopping
transactions for four to five days while
this supposed merger is happening with
quote world-renowned banks and fund
companies that we can't
we can't disclose to you right now and
understandably this is a little cryptic
and people start
like immediately panicking because look
crypto isn't new to exchanges going
bust overnight mount gox quadriga cx are
just a few examples of how you can lose
millions of dollars in a flash so
immediately investigations start first
bloomberg picks up the story and it
immediately goes viral this is the first
story reporting on this
that i know of april 21st and the next
day the story gets even
more damning a photo of the founder
farook ozer was snapped
at the istanbul airport apparently
fleeing to albania this is where people
start going like
a completely insane because people
realize look if this guy's pulling an
exit scam
it could be worth billions of dollars
now at this point you may be convinced
that
he did steal the money and is on the run
and apparently officials were pretty
convinced as well because
at this point a warrant goes out for
this guy's arrest and they freeze his
accounts but this is where the story
of course gets weirder because the next
day thoughtx re-updates its website with
a
another cryptic note i guess they're
trying to address the speculation here
now i'm not going to make you read this
whole thing it's quite long
basically it says look this deal with
investors
is very real he's not fleeing the
country
according to him this farooq guy he is
simply having final meetings with
investors uh he also states that
the 2.2 billion dollars that was claimed
to have been stolen
it's overblown although at the same time
he says at most it was probably millions
that was stolen which i'm sure was
comforting he then wraps it up by
accusing the press
of creating a self-fulfilling cycle
because if his accounts are frozen
the company can't continue its
commercial life thereby
i guess proving the uh cynicism right
in the end because the cryptocurrency
exchange will crash either way
so basically he's not a scammer he's a
victim
of the media and a reactionary
government now i think the most
interesting thing
in this statement is that farook says he
will return to turkey within a few days
and will make the facts come to light
now this statement was made over a week
ago and farook
has not returned to turkey like he said
he would but meanwhile the manhunt for
him has intensified because according to
reports
turkish authorities detained at least 83
people over connections to thodex
more recently his sister and brother
were arrested as well
and interpol put out something called a
red notice on it which is like an
international fugitive
notice but where does that leave us
right is farook ozer
a victim or a villain i think several
clues can point us
towards the answer you know besides the
anonymous investors sketchy freezing of
the accounts i think we can have a real
answer here
our first clue comes from whitestream
this is a company that basically digs
through blockchains to find out you know
sketchy patterns of behavior and
according to them
from august 2020 to february 2021
an estimated 5 000 bitcoin which is 125
million dollars
were sent from thodex turkish exchange
to kraken fx another popular
crypto exchange based here in the states
they accuse thodex of a
cash out operation and they of course
list
some blockchain samples for other people
to look at now i don't think thodex
probably has a good explanation for this
maybe it's another cyber attack on them
that they will disclose to us but
there's an
even more damning piece of evidence
believe it or not
that this was totally coordinated on
april 16th
before the collapse turkey had announced
that they were banning crypto payments
coming into effect at the end of the
month as part of sort of a
regulatory crackdown on cryptocurrencies
how ironic that this whole thing would
come falling apart sort of proving them
right only a few days later
the day after this announcement april
17th a twitter account named
cedric gerard right here noted that
thodex started selling dogecoin
for 30 under market price
and was withholding the coins when
people tried to recover them
sounds like an escape strategy all this
coinciding with the doge pump
they traded 500 million dollars of doge
within 24 hours and then you can see
right here it is
time stamped this is before the crypto
exchange basically goes bust
and this is massive because it shows
definitively
that they were luring investors with
cheap
rates and with holding withdrawals
apparently before the collapse ever
happened in other words possibly trying
to extract the maximum
amount of value from their clients again
look right here
you don't have to trust me look at the
exchange
thodex was quoting doge at 20 cents
while everyone else was quoting it
anywhere between 27 cents and 29 cents
there's no reason that this should be
the case
unless something very fishy is going on
now on those days where dogecoin was so
discounted how much volume did they do
that day
it was record-breaking 1.7
billion dollars now what does all of
this mean
right i think it's clear that farouk
knew this was coming
and manipulated the exchange to steal
from users
before running away not only that
there's evidence he had been stealing
from people
the whole time as early as february of
2020
but where does that leave us right what
can we learn because the international
manhunt's going on but we have no idea
whether they're going to catch farook at
all they haven't caught onecoin's
founder
they haven't caught quadriga cx's
founder i think we can learn two things
either way
number one don't fall for fancy deals at
sketchy exchanges
it's really common for people to sign up
and deposit money
with completely unreputable exchanges
all because they want to save a few
pennies
buyer beware this is often a trap if you
see your favorite coin listed for
cheaper than anywhere else
it's probably because no one trusts
trust that exchange just frankly and
that's a good reason that you shouldn't
either
the second thing you should learn
definitively is that you
have to own your own wallet ladies and
gentlemen it's a hard lesson
and i'm not sure how many times we're
gonna have to relearn it no crypto
exchange is immune from hacks or
criminal founders and if you leave your
crypto with one of these exchanges it is
not
safe and it is not insured invest in a
cold wallet and store your crypto
safely offline otherwise you may be
caught holding the bag like these
dodec's
victims and you have no recourse these
people their money
it's probably gone or in the best case
it's locked up for years
as the government if they ever find this
guy tries to give back the money now all
in all that basically concludes our
thodex investigation but i do
hope you take these lessons to heart do
not trust sketchy exchanges no matter
how good their prices are
and store your money outside of these
exchanges
either the hot wallets or the cold
wallets either way
they're centralized at these
institutions you cannot trust them i'll
continue to update you as we learn more
about this thodex
situation so if you'd like to know more
subscribe you can hit the bell
either way guys i hope you learned
something um i hope you enjoyed
and that's basically it i'll see you
guys in the next one